[muzyka]
sala poleciała
dla ciebie usiądę
[muzyka]
tuż przed panią, a przede mną gra
więźniowie
[muzyka]
tyle po ostrzale mostu gradobiciem
uderzenie w dom
[muzyka]
TAk
fabryka została oczywiście zabita wcale
tarly 2 poleciał kieliszek lo karl 4
przyjazd na końcu szyldu Chersoń mamy ją
zobacz czy mogę
rozpieszczony
gdy
tak jak
jeśli Chersoń
ale
[muzyka]
[śmiech]
sdo przestrzeń na ukrainie
jesteśmy białymi z białego domu
dzierganie teraz pieprzonego kuszącego łuku
dossier zabiera
[muzyka]
[oklaski]
dzisiaj wszyscy czekaliśmy na przystojnego mężczyznę
pieprzyć nas wszystkich, po prostu dobrze zrobione nikt
nic nas nie zabrało, a wszystkie ciężarówki są pełne
wróć do pieprzenia skąd pochodzą
[oklaski]
Ukraina
[muzyka]
myszy
[oklaski]